la fan de télé qui vous fait fantasmer
tiens allez un coup nous disaient qu'ils
allaient mettre maintenant non c'est
faux c'est vrai mais moi j'ai choisi la
droite sont jour les règles sont ce
travail en amont
non mais qui faisait je m'en fous
totalement ses talons rejoindre alors à
l'accord maintenant avec vous vous bail
mais bon allez
laury thilleman avons une petite manawi
a ouais ouais ouais bon alors c'est moi
c'est pas mon délire arrêtée elle est
sublime c'est pas mon délire là les
berges mais vous n'allez pas m'obliger
ça je suis tranquille moi j'ai rien
demandé
achèvement alémanique alors moi comme
chez un petit peu différent olivier
minne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
il
c'est tout comme en solitaire d'une
mauvaise année et c'est tout ce qui me
fait dresser une personne âgée de 50 ans
intelligent chaque fois qu'ils font
l'amour s'appelle indra la tête alors
vous quel est alors l'animatrice une
fantasmagorie jean marie c'est vrai moi
non personne moi mec bacha peu tard mais
concernant robert robin
[Applaudissements]
il est magnifique c'est vrai victoire
thébaux monsieur soya je vais te dire
c'est franchement tu remonte le niveau
sur ces vitesses non mais vous alors
vous moi c'était un saint clair avant 7
sur 7 je trouvais ses yeux bleus face et
non et maintenant c'est le père sexy
aurait pu sceller cette fragilité elle
est mignonne comme tout là elle et elle
est toujours belle anne sinclair voilà
désormais chinois est toujours un bon
ballon du des conneries mais si on ne
les sent pas vous voir mais voilà
nicolau
vous êtes nicolas mélissa theuriau oui
très mois carole rousseau soyez flèche a
autrefois c'est dorothée la maintenance
et carole rousseau mais vous avez besoin
de lire vos fiches à la fin de
croissance et d elle a besoin
alors on m'a dit alors l orgasme et
arrivera un jour qu avec tomboy dans ta
gueule
[Rires]
je sais c'est l'icône on a un mec c'est
nikos à la hausse j'adore banny
consommer rien à voir j'imagine nico
sont en train de faire l'amour
vas-y mon loulou basile je te faire ta
fête à riga mozy a fait l'unanimité
[Rires]